class today we have a new student from
the earth science department
say hi to Lonnie Turpin hi Lonnie hello
what's happening hey Lonnie you're cool
do you only do a thousand-page puzzle
with me sometime no I'm just anxious to
learn and try new things let's just say
some students and their professor are
bad eggs and they need to be removed
from this fine institution
what do you mean like try new things
like glamping yeah something like that
I'm professor rich expert in science
these are my devoted students together
with the aid of harmless drugs we
explore Sciences greatest hypothetical
questions
cats also known as felis catus average
lifespan 15 years one of the top 200
animals I like dogs no dogs suck yeah
cat no I'm afraid it's dogs something to
take the edge off you mean like a
smoothie hmm okay cool your jets
what if cats became extinct I would be
very sad because I love cats let's not
have a relapse okay relapse I like to
run around in circles for a minute okay
but don't make any noise yeah
what illegal drugs do you think he's on
Oh oh no no he's just a super big weirdo
I can hear you guys I decided to meet an
expert on dinosaurs who would know
better about extinction than a dinosaur
expert I'm going to be taking my glasses
on and off throughout the interview I
just thought I would warn you that I
appreciate the heads-up now your
specialty do you deal with extinction we
deal a lot with extinction in
paleontology now what is an animal that
might be in danger of being extinct
right now the Iberian lynx is a good one
in the cat family
possum possum not so much okay I just
thought maybe possum what if cats became
extinct all of them it would be a very
interesting phenomenon it would result
in a loss of a very charismatic group of
mammals
how would a cat become extinct what
would be the scenario for this sort of
thing happening so a lot of this is kind
of speculation in terms of what would
cause a species extinction a lot of what
I deal is speculation that doesn't
surprise me either but a lot of the time
when we're dealing with domesticated
organisms whether they be
crops or animals you can see reduce
levels of genetic diversity and that
sometimes makes them more susceptible to
disease
I say you're a dog person this interview
is done I smoke a marijuana cigarette
with one Leonard Kravitz I don't say
this very often but you are ah anyway
let's conduct an experiment okay now
this is an ecosystem with cats as an
integral part okay
this is when we take out the cats see
how it's changed whoa
cheese consumption is almost down to
nothing mm-hmm what the is gonna
happen to cheese burgers
oh speaking of cheese burgers I've got a
wicked case of the munchies no I guess
we'll just have to light up who's
holding oh I've got a huge stash right
here let me find as an agent of eastern
Montana State they're balls of cheese
never so yummy t'lani what were you
saying about being an agent uh nothing
I'm Asian 100% Japanese actually so I
needed to go straight to the source
that's right a cat lady
what if okay this is a cat yes right
that is a cat what is the possibility
that cats became extinct would you be
doing something else
what other animals would you be I think
it would be helping horses awesome I
would help an opossum I've helped many
of them for society in general how we
would react I would say it might be a
cat Astra fee well cats have been
domesticated since the Egyptians so it's
about 4000 years so cats definitely
serve a purpose in our society they do
they actually do serve a purpose a lower
blood pressure and their studies that
are shown
children who grow up with mommy you're a
good mommy just don't let go the irony
is I'm allergic to cats
yeah but do you take anything for it
uppers downers Midler's meth well an
antihistamine
who else takes some but state your name
first clearly and loudly Jenny
all right near D Wells the jig is up I'm
finally shutting down this low class
class
well why drug use and I got it all on
tape whoa new guy's a narc
Lonnie's a narcoleptic you can't fire me
I've got tenure ten year twelve miles
away what if you want to construct it
Joseph consider this class terminated
sometimes I think I'm a cat round
boy it's sure good to not be teaching
anymore yes too bad you're just a big
stupid loser now yeah you're just gone I
kind of wish you were dead right now
he's left